hey YouTube versus Charlie really
awesome news the flash people said
they're bringing back the zoom black
flash this is going to be a breakdown of
what's going on and how I think the TV
show is going to use in this season a
lot of you saw this and totally
recognize that because of the change in
his costume he was turning into the
black flash of the comics because
previously the show had been using the
time rates as like a stand-in for what
the black flash represented in the
comics now not to be confused with the
black racer the black flash is kind of
like a version of the black racer but
just for people with Speed Force powers
for like the flash family so it seems
like what the show's doing is it's just
upgrading the time race to actual black
flash from the comics so the way they're
using the black flash is way more comic
book accurate he'll be like a white
Walker on the flash he even kind of
looks like a white Walker and if you
don't watch Game of Thrones White
Walkers are kind of like the narrative
representation of death they're like a
force of nature so it seems like the
show's going to be using the zoom black
flash in that context now we don't know
what kind of story he's coming back for
like what the actual story of the
episode will be how many times we're
going to see him we just know that he's
coming back and even the actor Teddy
Sears was saying that when you know when
they were conceiving of the finale like
the final couple episodes gonna do this
really big comic book a story but leave
things in a way that would allow him to
return but would also resolve the zoom
arc in a satisfying way so like you know
they wrapped up the zoom plot but also
teed up a black flash like they upgraded
their zoom to black flash so now he can
come back anytime he wants and one of
the really cool things about zoom that I
think got lost in everything is that he
can travel the multiverse without
technology like his powers his Speed
Force powers enable him to do that there
was actually an episode I think it was
20 - it was like the black siren episode
where all the metahumans go crazy from
Earth to on earth one they had to take
them down
zoom escapes back to earth to by
punching a hole in the space-time
continuum opening a breach allowing him
to travel through just him he doesn't
need like a big device like they used in
STAR Labs so what that means is is that
the black flash now can travel the
multiverse killing as many flashes as he
wants but there's like an infinite
number of worlds so there's an infinite
number of flashes so hopefully they'll
have fun with that idea and hopefully
the writers will recognize that he is
kind of like the white Walker or even
the knight king of the TV show now but
it's not like he's going to raise a
black flash core would that be awesome
that'd be a backdoor to blackest night
like you have your Black Lantern Corps
they could do that with flashes that are
killed by the black flash like he could
turn them into other versions of the
black flash that look all desiccated
like him like a skeleton running around
in a flash suit that would be like the
most expensive thing they could ever do
so maybe they'll save that for like
season 4 season 5 let me know in the
comments though what do you want them to
do with the black flash when he comes
back and do you want to see like a
version of blackest night that's led by
the black flash would that be amazing
you could do that without the Green
Lantern Corps obviously they wouldn't
have Lantern rings but it would just be
another really cool reason to force all
the speedster villains that haven't been
turned into black flashes to team up
with the flash family you always want
that one episode where Barry has to work
with the villains like he needs
something from them in the villains are
forced to help him and then afterwards
they go back to being enemies like I
think it was episode 17 where Barry goes
back in time to get the information from
reverse flash Harrison wells he finds
him out but then Barry tells him if you
don't help me we're all screwed so he's
like fine here you go here's the Tachyon
device plans so you can get faster and
beat zoom so cannot wait to see zoom
black flash come back again I know it's
going to get a little confusing because
most people will cease avatar and
they'll think of him as the black flash
but technically the black flash is a
different character so whenever I'm
doing episode videos this season I'll
just try to be clear about which flash
I'm talking about when I say the black
flash but the other big news is kind of
like the rogue war that's going to be
going on throughout the season I don't
know how big that arc is going to be if
it's only going to be a small part of
the season or if it's going to go all
the way through the back half of the
season because we have our big gorilla
city two-part episode that'll be a
little more self-contained but if you
don't know what rogue war is is just an
arc from the Geoff Johns era of the
flash comics where a bunch of the Rogues
start fighting with each other so the
show has just started announcing new
characters this bringing on they just
announced top and mirror master they're
kind of like a team they announced
captain
it's coming back and now they just
announced another new flash rogue to
bringing on called magenta so I like the
idea that there's more female flash
rogues but her powers are actually
really interesting she's kind of like a
magneto type character she controls
magnetism like she can create a force
field that will block the flash that he
can't phase through so it'll be
interesting to see how they play with
that but in the comics she was like a
girlfriend of Wally West's but in the
grand tradition of people getting weird
powers that they can't deal with she
kind of goes a little bit nuts and Wally
tries to help her but it goes sideways
so I'm hoping that when we meet her for
the first time she hasn't actually
joined the flash Rose she's just like a
normal person with powers and then it
kind of goes downhill in grand fashion
after that but the version of the Rogues
that she was a member of was a team that
was led by blacksmith so I'm hoping that
they bring blacksmith on the show
eventually just another really awesome
female flash rogue but she kind of has
like this
techno Kinesis meta organic ability to
integrate tech into her biology so Star
Trek fans will really like this she's
kind of like a Borg like she's part
person part machine but she has the
ability to integrate technology with her
body but I'm just really happy that
they're bringing a lot of like really
fun really weird female flash rogues on
it is gonna be one of the best seasons
ever
we have white walkers white walkers on
the flash but if you guys didn't know in
related news there is a new round of the
DC giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video
there is a new spider-man video that I'm
working on they announced a whole bunch
of characters from the comics that
they're doing there was like a casting
sheet that came out so I'm gonna do a
video for that next but there's like a
whole bunch of other stuff that's been
happening like they just announced the
Guardians are going to crossover with
vendors infinity war why you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
the Avengers infinity war
guardians of the galaxy crossover teaser
and you can click here for the
spider-man homecoming Mary Jane video
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you